Chris do it hi guys its overhead again
that was Ben again okay no countdown
just just [ __ ] doing
I got he's civil right again and I am
here bringing you another yes
no thank you okay with this wooden
roller coaster again
oh my god well it's that's a such a nice
realistic B&M trek what's the elephant
doing on it oh my god you know what you
should do you should make a coaster in
your park with that not in my Park it's
a room oh and then be like it's Hannibal
and Hannibal with his elephant's and
everything in me Hannibal comes right
yes
see ya I would actually that would
actually fit in there ya have a mountain
themed bride handles trip through the
Alps and then you just have a death
coaster oh yeah oh look who else through
this Tyler oh I thought that was max
just be in the silent [ __ ] now my sister
came in so I had to mute my microphone
stuff can i play no you're playing shut
up are you are you are you are you are
you are you your your temp they needed
to spam that are you no no I snake
smokey are you
okay so this is basically the lag that I
have to put up with all the time it's
house killing me yeah yeah it's nice
that you're asking me that you're in my
let's play right now and you you thank
God my self like cults that's one of the
disadvantages of being in a Skype call
with me yeah yeah oh wait you know I
know some disadvantages of [ __ ] fraps
I'm on one frame per second again are
you are you are you are you yes young
man John man I didn't make jokes about
you and be sensitive about jokes about
Germans I mean sure you're German but
all right well what to stuff has
happened so long ago it doesn't even
matter where you're from anymore
yeah Germany is now probably the most
politically correct country well frankly
I can't and frankly
are you are you are you are you attached
to this I think yeah yeah I did all the
supports now you still have to do just a
few footers but then I'm finished can
you guys believe it
not really I know I can't you just
thought I'd say that to make you feel
happy I can't believe your [ __ ] go
away
yep I'm finished I've done this boom
finished I've done all the supports this
monster coaster this humongous woody
with many supports I've done it and
likely like like I think hate it I'm
thinking that would be this episode I
mean I think I've done everything I see
we did then I see what you did there see
what you did there
what would be this episode so on yeah I
think there'll be this episode because
who cares about Rolla Q skin 3 when
theme park studio comes out tomorrow
think back Cydia I'm alright yeah I
agree with me oh yeah I'm probably going
to I don't know get theme box to do as
soon as I can which is in one day and
zero hours according to steam which is
amazing and I'm going to I think I'm
going to open it just get my fraps
hopefully it works and just record me as
I'm trying to do something in that as
you fairly going to be the biggest Rolly
trying to learn any game in your life
but that doesn't matter I just I just
need to play that again
so yeah I'm going to close it no Lucas
can three now and open theme park studio
though I'm still going to continue my
let's play episode though but everybody
yeah till next time